en el vídeo anterior tenemos esta taza
con tapa y vacío aquí adentro
el fluido de arriba cubre un área a uno
y en la parte de abajo perforamos un
hueco con una área más pequeña a dos que
es una milésima parte del área de la
superficie de la tasa
y usamos la ecuación de continuidad en
donde la velocidad en la superficie de
uno
de 1 x 1 tiene que ser igual a la
velocidad de salida de 2 multiplicará
por el área de salida a 2 y vimos que
esta velocidad uno por uno es igual a b
2 por a 1 entre 1.000 quitamos a 1 en
ambos lados de la ecuación y encontramos
que la velocidad de entrada es igual a
ave 2 entre 1000 por lo que ya tenemos
los tres elementos del lado izquierdo de
la ecuación de berlín y ahora veamos los
elementos de lado izquierda vuelve a ser
la presión en este punto donde tenemos
el hueco vamos a reescribir la ecuación
debe nula la presión de entrada a uno
más la densidad por la gravedad por la
altura uno más la densidad del líquido
por la velocidad de entrada al cuadrado
entre dos es igual a la presión de
salida más la densidad por la gravedad
por la altura
más la densidad por la velocidad de
salida al cuadrado entre 2
la presión en este punto de salida la
ecuación de berlín nos dice cuál es la
presión externa a este agujero
recordemos que cuando desarrollamos esta
ecuación
estos términos representaban el trabajo
que se ejerce en ese punto si vemos el
líquido que está saliendo del agujero
veremos que no está haciendo trabajo
alguno ya que no está ejerciendo ninguna
fuerza contra algo si pensamos en la
presión de salida no se da la presión a
esta profundidad sino la presión
específicamente en el agujero y en este
caso no hay presión externa digamos que
si cerramos o si está paramos este
agujero en este punto tendríamos la
presión que ejerce el líquido a esa
profundidad para contener el agua en la
taza y terminaríamos con una velocidad
de salida igual a cero porque no
tendríamos líquido que esté escapando
aquí
pero como si tenemos un hueco si hay un
hueco acá
nuestra presión será igual a cero así
que diremos que nuestra presión 2 es
igual a 0 y también recordemos que la
presión 1 es igual a 0 ya que arriba hay
un vacío por lo que ambas presiones son
cero esta es cero y esta también es cero
uno es la presión externa al líquido en
el tubo técnicamente podríamos ver que
este contenedor es como un tubo de hecho
puedo redibujar la taza original de
manera que esta es la entrada
y en este extremo tengo un hueco
chiquitito chiquitito
y aquí afuera
va a haber un vacío
y en esta abertura pequeñita es lo de
escaparía líquido así que la presión
externa a la entrada es cero y como hay
un hueco a la salida la presión externa
a la salida es cero también por lo que
no hay trabajo y cuál va a ser este
término de densidad por gravedad por
altura esa es la energía potencial
tenemos la densidad
y vimos que ve uno
es esto por lo que tenemos la densidad
si sustituimos esto acá la densidad
entre 2
por la velocidad 2 entre 1000
al cuadrado y sustituimos esto aquí
queremos que la presión exterior de
salida es 0 y cuál va a ser esta altura
2 como indicamos en el dibujo este
agujero se encuentra a h igual a 0 a una
altura de 0 por lo que está h 2 va a ser
cero y todo este término va a ser cero
por lo que sólo nos queda el término de
la energía cinética que es densidad por
velocidad 2 al cuadrado entre 2 una de
las cosas que podemos ver inmediatamente
aquí es que tenemos la densidad rock en
ambos términos por lo que los podemos
quitar dividiendo todo entre ron y
también podemos multiplicar ambos lados
de la ecuación por 2 y así nos quedaría
h 1
este término velocidad 2 al cuadrado
/ cuánto es mide al cuadrado es un
millón
un millón
esto va a ser igual a la velocidad 2 al
cuadrado podemos observar que este
término
es muy muy muy pequeño y si esta área
por ejemplo en lugar de ser un milésimo
fuera un millonésimo del área de entrada
este término de aquí sería todavía muy
muy muy pequeño casi insignificante por
lo que podríamos ignorar
es como hacer un agujero a la presa
hoover la presa hoover contiene y
detiene a un gran río por la que ese
agujero sería una fracción pequeñísima
de la superficie del fluido así que sólo
podemos eliminar este término de la
ecuación cuando la diferencia de áreas
es muy grande y el agujero por donde
sale el líquido es muy pequeño
tomando en cuenta esto nos va a quedar
voy a reescribir cómo nos queda
la velocidad de salida 2 es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de 2 por g por h1 pero
creamos que h1 es igual a h
y esta es mi velocidad de salida mi
incógnita
y cuál es la cantidad de líquido que
sale cada segundo del agujero vamos a
dibujarlo aquí
puedo imaginar que aquí sale una columna
de líquido y en el tiempo t el ancho de
esta columna va a ser la velocidad por
el tiempo y la sección transversal de
esta columna va a ser igual al área del
agujero por donde sale va a ser igual a
2 si quiero conocer el flujo de salida
este flujo va a ser
igual al área de salida por la velocidad
de salida y sustituyendo esta velocidad
de salida
tendremos que es igual a 2 por raíz
cuadrada de 2 por g por h
más adelante usaremos esta fórmula
usando cantidades nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo